en hausse à ça je crois que j'ai deviné
c'est pour faire on va faire une soupe
c'est presque ça la soupe au pistou
aulas va pas je comprends qu'on puisse
pas si j'allais manger souvent oui mais
sûrement pas aussi bonne que la vôtre
est bonne nous allons voir nous allons
grandir ses classes
d'ailleurs les gens qui mange de la
soupe sont toujours des gens
intéressants dans mange prie la zone
nord oui bon alors qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour aider alors voilà dans la
soupe au pistou d'abord des les
ingrédients qui manquent c'est bien là
la conception il y a la courgette et
carottes des haricots verts de
préférence et haricots plats ou c'est
que l'on appelle larry groupe à ce sont
des ragots qui sont en trop long et
assez plat et large du céleri du poireau
des pommes de terre
ensuite des haricots darricau blanc
lorsqu'on a la chance d'être en saison
des haricots grain nouveau on m'aide à
ricoh gr nouveau mais comme ceux ci sont
des
jeux c'est plus agréable la peau est
moins épaisse mais comme là nous sommes
pas encore à la saison derrick aux
nouveaux j'ai pris des haricots secs que
j'écris auparavant parce que sinon ils
sont trop longs à cuire et puis des
tomates de l'ail et du basilic voilà
même revient sur de l'huile d'olive
possible
après ça j'ai prévu parce que la soupe
est quand même à plat un plat important
et cela de résistants représente
après ça on va faire une dorade rôti aux
lauriers en étant légèrement sous la
peau de feuilles de laurier et on le
rôti sur l'it fenouil
sur sur une grille enfin comme on en a
marre de vue on peut le faire au beurre
l'est aussi et puis on le sert avec une
fondue d'orange et de citron avec
l'huile d'olive toujours à l'huile
d'olive on continue
ensuite un fromage de banon
et
commençait coup un peu mou non non non
pas c'est qu'au contraire de 13 mois le
roulé dans la feuille de châtaignier est
très mal et puis après ça une golden une
pomme golden au
long des contrats avec avec une liqueur
d'orange et de la crème voilà et on boit
et on va boire un ermitage blanc peut
faire un héritage dont surtout le repas
puisque avec le poisson ça ira très bien
même avec le fromage de chèvre le ballon
ira très bien aussi bon alors nous
allons commencer de préparation
ce qui est important voiliers a fait il
ya par exemple la courgette la courgette
on ne rate elles sont toutes des toutes
petites courgettes on ne les paye même
pas du tout celle ci est un peu plus
grosse on va appeler que une part sur
deux pays on laisse une prendre pour le
goût pour le goût et la couleur aussi
qui va être communiqué
alors après ça pour les couper on
appelle ça coupait en paysanne on en
fait d'abord des grandes bandes
dans un sens c'est ce que j'aime le
moins faire moi c'est là où le risque
plus de se couper des lois
alors là dépendre dans ce sens ensuite
on les reprend dans l'autre sens la
vendons toujours
pour faire les petites pour faire les
petits la petite paysanne pour l article
on va retirer pour ne pas mélanger
voilà alors là on fait pression sur la
pointe du couteau
mais ce alors qu'il a attention on y
arrive après plusieurs mois
d'entraînement lors donc on apprendra
plus longtemps parce que pour chaque
chacun des légumes ont notamment agi de
la même façon
un petit peu long
alors on met un peu d'huile d'olive
un peu je veux dire environ 4 cuillères
la la soupe c'est pour six au moins ont
ils arrivent il en restera encore mais
elle al'avantage on peut la manger
froides aussi aller il est aussi
agréable à manger froide ou tiède et
réchauffé alors voilà on glisse tout
seul
dans la cocotte avec l'huile
à feu doux on peut faire à ses finances
et fort tout de même
il suffit de il ne faut pas faire
rissoler simplement
faire suer c'est à dire faire rendre
l'eau légumes
surtout pas ne pas les colorer ballon
dans la soupe au pistou on peut rajouter
aussi des petits points
c'est très rapide la plus demandée
beaucoup d'eau là dedans suffit de cinq
minutes
si l'on va plus rapide l'on peut le
faire plus longuement en le couvrant
aussi là je vous avais remarqué j'ai pas
mis les pommes de terre présente les
points d'attaché est coupé g zerrin
c'est après les avoir taillé j'ai passé
sous l'eau et goûté on émettra qu'un
dernier moment avec les
voilà je vous le voyez chez vous
attendez commerce a inversé comme ça on
là ça fait environ 2 litres et demi de
litres et demi de l'escb pour 6 ou
alors la voyez de l'ébullition
va reprendre
on va sur l'élite au très chaud
bouillant enfin on peut le mettre à
l'eau froide mais là puisqu'on 20
on va aller plus vite
à l'eau
froide parce qu'on a le temps m'a fallu
suffirent pas une grosse différence
en agissant d'une façon ou de l'autre
alors là je mets les pommes de terre
d'ébullition est parti ça beau jeu mais
les pommes de terre
haricots on va attendre que les pommes
de terre aux parts et en mettra les
haricots et ça va très vite
on ajouté alors là vous avez vu juste
allé
saluer alors j'ai salle est d'environ
une grosse cuillère à café en rebutera
maintenant s'il faut rajouter en ramant
remettra
mais c'est un peu tôt encore à leur
coûtera toute l'année c'est quand même
pas de ma cuillère voilà là je mets les
haricots
c'est une soupe qui doit être tout de
même assez épaisse
voilà alors là maintenant on va
l'oublier
pendant 20 minutes on allait sans
bouillir à couvert vous la couvrir oui
mon ancien tous côtés les pommes de
terre des haricots les trouverez on met
tout bon de légumes et on laisse partir
maintenant de ce fait combien de temps à
peu près aujourd'hui là il va falloir
environ 20 minutes puisque les haricots
sont cuits si l'on mettait des haricots
secs ça demanderait beaucoup trop
longtemps
pour tout le reste des légumes auraient
perdu saveur voilà alors maintenant va
reprendre notre part de la soupe au
pistou qui est la liaison et qui a son
importance c'est elle qui donne un
caractère à la soupe sinon ça ne ferait
qu'une soupe de légumes lors lampre par
les tomates
alors on coupe les tomates en deux pour
les épépiner
payer
apprends les prêts seront l'ipres et
pour remettre tout ça dans le mixeur
pour en faire une purée on la voyait
j'ai mis pour cinq ou six personnes j'ai
mis environ une tomate par personne
il faut les choisir le plus mûr
possibles celles ci sont un peu pâle
tout le maire
n'en manquait de soleil
n'oublions pas que l'on est au printemps
on en attend un autre
pardon alors là je vais commencer à
broyer la tomate
va pas aller trop vite
il va falloir que je rajoute un peu de
liquide alors là de là il va nous
falloir lui de lui louis
on en sait en laisse
on allait se transformer non ça ne
risque pas de l'aïe
on va mettre
pour la voyez 5 gousses donc pour les
six personnes cinq médailles
alors toujours pareil
on écrasait
et on pèle
et en couple dit
la petite partie brune
j'ai passé écrasé rien oui on met dedans
voilà
sur lorsqu'il ya de la haine nouveau
aussi c'est il faut forcer un peu parce
qu'il est moins fort
alors le basilic maintenant
assez en levier toujours
patron saint nom parce qu'on va le
mettre dans le mixeur aussi
davantage du mixeur voyez par exemple
les tiges tendre on peut les mettre
parce que ils vont être broyés aussi
la donne beaucoup oui
comment ça c'est la finition de la soude
ensemble
et pis tout ça devient pistou que ça
c'est un pistolet parce que trop souvent
on appelle le basilic le pistou mais le
basilic reste le basilic il ne devient
pistou que quand il est mélangé à 7 dans
cette composition de tomates et d'haïti
et d'huile alors là je tiens compte que
j'ai déjà mis un peu d'huile pour six
personnes il faut à peu près un demi des
six litres d'huile alors la jeunesse
famille tout à fait j'en rajoute encore
un peu
voilà je crois qu'ils ont nié
on va donner un tour de moulin à peu
près 2 cuillères à soupe d'huile
bon ça fait plus que ça non mais j'en
avais mis avant enfin au total ça fait à
peu près en idées si dit aussi personnes
noyées ça fait 5 centilitres
la
voilà ça sent on le garde comme c'est si
on regarde papa nos légumes qui si on va
surveiller la soupe maintenant aller à
décrire dit non mais il faut que sa
cuisine voyez ça s'écrase et les
haricots vont se mettre presque en purée
dans assez bon les maquis hier à la
louche la suite
et là vous pouvez déjà la goutte et
marthe on va voir si l on doit rajouter
du sel
avec ce ne soit pas terminé
tel un petit peu confiance et
c'est déjà bien parfumée voilà alors
valu des siens de corps est un peu juste
et on va lui laisser encore un bonne
minute parce qu'il faut bien 20 minutes
au moins deux cuissons ça en vaut deux
portes non parce que sans le goûtera
après lorsque l'on rajoutait dedans
bon vous savez ce que l'on va pouvoir
faire je vous montrer comment prépares
les pommes les pommes golden bon départ
marque le citron de la crème mais
alors ça vous la mettez là dedans on
aurait pu la monture misé sur
l'électrique ah bah si vous voulez quand
on n'est pas tellement pour un jeu
ouvert s'en va retirer ça et là je le
trouvais le bol d'abord la flore est au
fond que l'on commence suivant vos
conseils très lentement
alors là la crème il y en a où il y en a
même pas ça fait une tasse une bonne
tasse ka sat est une tasse à thé on
commence tout doucement en lanvin
celui-ci
accélérer après voilà lors de ce temps
on va préparer les pommes
alors chaque pomme il me faut une
cuillère à pomme parisienne mais petite
cuillère un ebit pomme
là on fait on enlève le chapeau
de ceux ci
voyez là on retire
le centre de la pomme
il faut pas crever le
faux pas crever dessous hélas la
cuillère à pomme parisienne ont fait des
boules là je vais prendre la petite
alors de ce temps notre circuit
l'attaquant a créé monte
et quand on passera à table on aura tous
notre repas de près
une fois convaincu ni ma trail
vous pouvez l'oublier un peu vous savez
m
c'est les villas maintenant
alors là je peux atteindre
pour veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
graines qui reste dedans grâce à vienne
du beurre non il n'y est pas encore
mais on fait une petite boule mais sans
crever le
roy de la pomme pour en faire une autre
voilà
à voir la forme voyais été vidés
dans l'est on a le couvert
voilà
là vous marquez ne le prenez pas la même
et elle cela t'a pas ce que j'espérais
doublé c'est comme ça va
c'est allé trop fort je n'allais pas
dire oui
la petite
on va presser le jus de citron pour nos
pâtes les pommes noircissent mais un
faible du titre ont très peu
voilà
on va rajouter là tout de suite
et je m'appelle près de cuillères
marchés déçus
depuis hier vous
reste à battre le sucre dedans
mais il faut pas trouver les paroissiens
mourad
vous avez percée
mais fait des boules boyard yjc
abandon
mais il faut prendre plein de bol il
faut bien rentrer la cuillère
n'est pas ce qu'il est il a tourné
dedans il faut la rentrée complètement
voilà
c'est un peu de citron
alors ça voilà c'est presqu'une c'est
presqu'une demi bull au nom là on va
sucre et un peu aussi
non là il faut tenir compte que les
fruits le sont déjà à
l'arrêt pour vous celle ci
bon on va garnir les pommes et l'essai
avec la liqueur
le sucre tout ça tout est dedans
et makrem voilà alors là on met le sirop
la de liqueur qui est au fond on le
partage mais stoppé oui tweet c'est pour
ça que je me dépêche passé
la soupe est prête on va pouvoir passer
à table
bon ça nous le mettons comme ceux ci à
la glacière
apprend le sortira pour le dessert
attention ne pas perdre et couverts
bon
alors donc
la soupe est cuite
c'était cool environ 20 25 minutes
depuis que nous l'avons mise en route là
je la retire
je la retire du du plein feu et je vais
rajouter ma liaison avec
la cuillère la voilà
parfait ça il faut le faire tout au tout
dernier moment et surtout ne pas la
faire bouillir parce que l'huile qui est
mélangée à la pulpe de tomate se
départagent répit viendront en appui le
dessus non il faut qu'elle émulsion
reste
alors là les tomates sont un peu pâle
mais quand on est en pleine saison des
tomates bien mûres elles sont rouges sa
colonne ça colore plus
on a suffi de le goûter oui
the good man
il fait du sel
mais c'est la version 7 succès c'est ça
le sel non parce que c'est la tomate là
que l'on a rajouté qu'elle en avait pas
salé
il adoucit
mais vous allez voir vous allez lettre
c'est une véritable soupe une soupe
épaisse
alors on peut mettre plus ou moins die
selon en ont pas plus sinon que l'on
aime on sait bien oui
que l'on va débarrasser
oui je ne pense pas qu'il ait utilisé de
la changer de classe non non non la
cocotte correspond bien à la soupe
alors tous les légumes sont un peu fondu
dedans mais il reste tout de même à
parents les retrouve retrouve la carotte
l'haricot la pomme de terre
les céleris les courgettes
alors on peut mettre aussi comme je le
disais maintenant des petits pois
on promet des fèves aussi
la saison nicolas
non comme on les laisse dans la glacière
les sens on va les sortir maintenant on
va pouvoir les terminer
notre crème est resté ferme
il ya la relâcher un peu on va la
reprendre au fouet
non mais tout simplement parce qu elle
est attendue elle revient tout de suite
alors ça on peut garnir à la cuillère ou
bien la poche vous savez avec une
une douille cannelée vous avez ça
marchera wii balance est merveilleux
voilà
la douille douille ce sens on peut
prendre une douille cannelée c'est à
dire une brouille avec des petites
griffes et 10,1 faut pas trop racines et
un mois déjà c'est compliqué alors
là pour la rentrée ce qui est facile en
a mais sur un fusil vous savez des
fusils que l'on église et août aux
salariés leur rentrer dedans alors qu'à
tout garni pour ne pas qu'elle
lorsqu'on va mettre la crème pour ne pas
qu elle s'écoule pendant que la gare ni
on tourne un peu comme un dé à coudre et
on a pu être un très bon
ces trucs de grand mère
alors là on peut vanille et la crème
aussi ou bien m on aurait pu faire une
petite trappe et de zestes d'orange
puisque là il y à la liqueur d'orange
alors là
simplement envoyé cancer mieux avec la
poche et là on pousse et ça fait une
petite queue qui sort ici c'est très
charmant
ça mérite un gros plan
appuyant oui
bouger
alors là vous servez puisqu'il reste de
la crème en la serre un peu en par
rajoutera si on le désire mais c'est à
dire très facile à faire et c'est très
bien comme ça
on
oui
non